from Hollywood it's the fifth annual
nanny of the Year awards
please welcome the only host we could
afford mr. Ted baliker thank you thank
you thank you good evening we may think
we know what's best for us but do we
really tonight reason TV pays tribute to
those who devote their lives to telling
us how to run ours and we begin with a
Lifetime Achievement Award presented to
the Meryl Streep of nannies here we look
back at the many ways the recently
turned out Mayor Michael Bloomberg
minded New Yorkers business in this
video montage video hold on how long is
this going to take 97 minutes 97 minutes
nope just cut it cut it the nominees for
nanny of the year are mitch green lick
the oregon state rep introduced a bill
that would expand the drug war by
categorizing cigarettes as a Schedule
three controlled substance on par with
LSD you'd need a prescription to buy
smokes and violators could face up to a
year behind bars mr. green that couldn't
be with us tonight due to a prior
engagement Halle Berry the actress and
humanitarian championed a new California
law that could jail photographers for up
to a year if they snapshots of
celebrities children without consent the
law also extends special protection to
the children of politicians Lewis
Fletcher
Anthony Colavito not satisfied with
banning traditional fast-food
restaurants the East Chester New York
supervisor decided to shield residents
from so-called fast casual restaurants
like Panera Bread and Chipotle mr. Kaul
evita couldn't be with us tonight due to
a prior engagement and the nanny goes to
Anton Halle Barry
this is howdy Barry's first nomination
and award hold it stop sit down Halle
I'm sorry sit down sit down we're gonna
give the nanny to that Chipotle banning
freak run the tape they can travel to
White Plains man Vernon Yonkers or New
Rochelle to get their fix of fast food
thanks for watching everybody you know
make sure to follow this show on Twitter
tell us about the people who make it
their business to mind your business
thanks for watching everybody I love you
good night
each Chester is a very upscale community
any of the other municipalities saying
you know what you know who do you guys
think you are seriously sure of course
people would think that but we are East
Chester and that's us and we're not
going to change and we're like the way
we are
I like that taking a stand